[Musik]
eigentlich nicht sich jetzt ein
schwarzer frack und meine allererste mal
angefangen sagt hallo fünf jahren genau
also hallo vor fünf jahren das aus
[Musik]
heute uns jetzt im jahr 2017
hallo herzlich willkommen so solid welt
heute möchte ich mein kind jähriges
jubiläum feiern auf youtube wenig aber
vor fünf jahren am ersten april 2012
gebacken und hochgeladen gebacken habe
ich ihm natürlich nicht an den tag aber
stabil hochgeladen und war mein
allererstes youtube video und ich war
schüchtern doch bewegt gab es wieder
vier mal gefilmt weil es mir nie
gefallen hat und ich damals schon sehr
pessimistisch war hab ich schon
mittendrin
ich wollte ruhig rein gelaufen bin ich
fragt was machst du er hat nicht einfach
nur ausgelacht erzählt unter den
zuschauern machte jetzt darüber gedacht
aus über mein video waren gekommen um
mit dem café der kamera ach ja warte bei
meiner rolle macht ihr hier und da hat
ja gesagt ich mache ganz bewusst davor
gar nicht was ja vorher ohne musik
plattform für uns und dann habe ich
gedacht kommt es gibt irgendwie keine
richtigen kochen back videos die auch
für anfänger geeignet sind keine
erklärte richtig klein schriftlich mit
einfachen flughafen und strukturiert und
so habe ich mich an das erste video
gewagt und ich habe gesagt okay trend
freude irgendwas ist unterwegs
und dann war da wenig seit fünf jahren
ja und da war sie zu viel gemacht habe
ich habe alles demokratischer schwabe
es ist sehr geizig oder schwarz geistig
bank die basis und einfach bei ihm
betreut problem weil wir 33 sachen in
rockige machen wir beide studierten kein
geld dazu und man hat ihnen doch
gefallen hat dass nicht jeder die kamera
gestellt und heute stehen wir hier mit
unseren zwei franken kaufen möchte dann
über die zutaten reichen wollten einfach
die torten geben praktisch nie verkaufen
kann aber über einer woche einfach die
zutaten und haben ja und ich habe am
anfang habe ich in der woche drei sachen
zu machen und dann hat er mich doch in
ruhe gelassen und ich habe immer
heimlich gebacken und habe mir gedacht
komm der wird schon irgendwann auch auf
den geschmack kommen
daher unterstützt mich sogar darauf also
heute feiern wir nicht gehen das tut die
ganzen kuchen und torten pressen und ich
habe jetzt heute auch wieder den stopp
für euch denn noch nicht alle haben
genug luft gesehen deswegen auf dem jahr
2017 gibt aktuelle version hat sich
nicht viel verändert ich mache nach wie
vor gerne mein notebook flat hätte es
nur ein paar chips noch mal für euch
dass er eben noch besser und noch was
die gratuliert und dachte mir zu diesem
anlass backen wir jetzt ein genau fünf
jahre später reichlich kilo schwerer
lasst uns einfach hier noch was helfen
genau ja und damit ihr diesen
wunderschönen nutzer zu bereiten könnte
ich sagte damals ich zeig euch jetzt wie
man benutzt supereinfach hersteller so
irgendwie habe ich fragte was ich sage
ich jetzt einfach mal die zutaten für
den hefeteig für den hefeteig brauche
ich einen würfel hefe zwei entschlossen
warmes wasser 80 gramm zucker einen
teelöffel salz 1 1 200 milliliter warme
milch 80 gramm flüssige butter und 500
gramm mailen sie mir zuerst einmal das
wasser darin löse ich nicht die hilfe
auf so verteilt ist nicht gut im teig
und sie kann auch wunderbar aufgehen
und da noch mit rein hilfe brauchte
möglichkeit und wärme damit so toll
aussehen kann alles auslösen
und dann werde ich den hier total gleich
in der küchenmaschine verkneten aber
falls ihr keine habt könnt ihr einfach
ganz normal auf hinteren kommen die
zutaten die küchenmaschine heim auf die
übrigen zutaten und die reihenfolge
komplett egal wer trocken immer ganz zum
schluss mit rein nämlich erstmal nur ein
bisschen medien kommt immer darauf an
wie groß das eigelb ist und dann
benötigt oder anders oder eben nur ein
teil davon
dann kann das zeigt schon geschmiedet
werden
[Musik]
der teig durch für ersten minuten lang
nähten und sobald er sich vom schlüssel
rand glück und beklebt ist das verdienst
zu einer kugel formen und dafür streue
ich bin ich bestreite die arbeitsfläche
mit etwas bremste ihr könnt auch betten
oder anderen butter zum beispiel nehmen
mit einer kugel formen auch die
schlüssel weg den teig wieder zurück und
fette auf den teig damit einfach nicht
aus darauf muss und jetzt können wir ihn
halten frauenhaus stellen zum beispiel
neben heizung oder auch die
fußbodenheizung immer schön abdecken
damit er nicht austrocknet
ich mache das hier ein kurz-comeback
drauf und können hier auch gleich zur
anlage und in der zwischenzeit während
dieser gehzeit etwa 30 60 minuten lang
aufgeht kann ich schon mal gefühl und
bereiten und ihr stimmt auch die zutaten
für die füllung frau ist 200 gramm nüsse
ich nehme ich die haselnuss einen
teelöffel zimt 20 30 zucker interessante
links ein eiweiß und etwas milch zuerst
nämlich jetzt die haare müssen
die muss ich einmal ihr könnt natürlich
auch gemahlen nehmen aber so schmecken
sie einfach viel aromatischer
falls die maschine arbeitet könnte jetzt
die übrigen zutaten hier mit rein geben
aber wir sehen könnt
in einer durch die kommen jetzt die
übrigen zutaten mit seinen akzent darauf
kennen hier auch immer ein bisschen mehr
sein kakaopulver kleiner bakker kunst
sein kann man einfach aber viel zu süß
schmeckt und instant kaffee drin steckt
dann natürlich eine extra und auch nur
noch so viel milch dass eine
streichfähige masse entsteht
[Musik]
die füllung abdecken und einfach noch
auf den teig warten
der hefeteig schön aufgegangen und jetzt
geht's los nehmen für die arbeitsplätze
sondern trägt nämlich wunderbar
ausrollen und dann kommt ja schon fast
von alleine raus
mit fröhlichen zeigt täglich aus und
achtet immer darauf dass eben nicht auf
der arbeitsliste fallenden trümmer
genügend e mail darunter seien jetzt 30
hier die füllung drauf einfach komplett
bis zum rand
[Musik]
und ein kleiner extra tipp von mir wenn
es gerne noch musiker haben wollt dann
nehmt einfach noch mal die hälfte dazu
taten und geht's hin so also mit 300
gramm möglich dann schmeckt wenn ich
richtig genial
jetzt wird der topf von unten heraus
[Musik]
entsteht auf diese rolle einem spot und
zwar schneidet hier längst durch erstmal
nur die hälfte damit letztlich
auseinanderfällt und auch performance
bei dem die handlung des lebens immer
einem strang über den anderen wo in
special ops und hier unten am ende
werden beide zusammengedrückt und
einfach darunter geschoben
hier genau das leid
[Musik]
die haben und ihn aus meiner
vorbereitete fakt folie
da habe ich jetzt meinen backpulver und
jetzt könnt ihr den slip entweder so
nochmal bei zimmertemperatur abgedeckt
aufgehen lassen oder ihr macht so wie
ich vorgehen bisschen schneller
insgesamt sieben jetzt in den kalten
backofen kommt und dann fällt den
backofen an und während der ofen aufgeht
hat er nochmal zeit aufzugehen
in den kalten backofen
und jetzt fehlen backofen auf 170 grad
ober unterhitze stellen und etwa 40
minuten backen lassen und war doch zu
dunkel wird einfach mit ein bisschen
runter nehmen am ende oder im ganzen
kanton abdecken
[Musik]
der profi selbst gebackenem ich habe ihn
ganz gut abkühlen lassen und jetzt kommt
das beste neben die klausur und wahr
mache ich da eine butter zucker zitrone
glasur die passt einfach geschmacklich
dazu nimmt dafür 150 gramm puderzucker
und den saft und etwa einer patrone mit
kürzeren weg mit ligatus entsteht im
kopf dass ich jetzt einfach mal um
wie gesagt erst noch schön warm dafür
muss ich jetzt eben dieses mammut
tablett nehmen bin ich hab dann sonst
nix drauf war
wenn ich einfach immer so groß wobei
ihnen sagen wenn ich ihn privat einfach
mache ohne kamera darüber steht
normalerweise hätten weil einfach so
lecker schmeckt deswegen wird er gleich
vom blech es jetzt kommt der kalte luft
auf den warmen socken
[Musik]
oliver morath ist otto der nutzer zu
probieren
ich muss dazu sagen wie oft habe ich
dann gemacht also bestimmt schon 200 mal
am tag
jetzt muss probieren acht jahre alt
damals ein blick voraus
das ist wirklich sehr schnell gemacht
und schmeckt immer also eine
live-sendung software setzt das deutsche
team auf ihrer party der kino bleiben an
jedem wochenende wecken bei jeder
schwiegermutter von otis von
schwiegermutter rezept himmler eindruck
schinden
das gibt's ja mein mann bin auch immer
frecher mit der zeit ja ich mal probier
mal sich der ruf erst ruiniert lebt es
sich ganz ungeniert kann den weg nicht
immer retten könnt ihr sehen wie waren
das können wir ja nicht erinnern aber
ich sozusagen zum von guten jungen
jahren konnten wir den nutzern weit
alleine auf essen wenn ich könnte zwar
immer noch aber wahrscheinlich machen
weil wir auch wenn jemand zehn minuten
weg
also dann nutzt sie gesagt falls ihr
euch noch nicht dran getraut habt dann
probiert jetzt auf jeden fall noch
einmal und das rezept steht auf meinem
blog auf realismus blog.de diesmal da
kann man schon sagen die fotos sind etwa
das video ist wahrscheinlich besser aber
ich bin froh dass ich damals die musste
zuschauen über die frieden
die zuschauer sagen fast ein jahr hatte
ich nicht so dann eigentlich
ob hoffmann licht und anderen kamera und
mikrofon und so haben wir es heute eben
schöne videos möglich einzufahren muss
zum slogan das seit angst hat mich mehr
mit ihr noch hinter der kamera gelaufen
eine woche nachdem sie gemerkt haben
halt immer so macht nichts aber trotzdem
sagt du bist unverzichtbar
also viel spaß beim nachbacken danke für
eure treue und fünf jahre
[Musik]
das ganze kommt von drei minuten